Max Weber is one of the philosophers
best able to explain to us
the peculiar economic system we live within called capitalism.
Born Erfurt in Germany in 1864,
Weber grew up to see his country
convulsed by the dramatic changes of the Industrial Revolution.
Cities were exploding in size.
Vast companies were forming.
A new managerial elite was replacing the old aristocracy.
Weber spent his life analyzing these changes
and he developed some key ideas with which we can better understand
the workings and future of
capitalism.
The standard view is that capitalism began
as a result of developments in
technology especially steam power.
But Weber proposed something more
interesting that what actually made capitalism possible
was a set of ideas
and in particular religious ideas
and not just any religious ideas.
Capitalism was created by Protestantism,
specifically Calvinism.
In his great work The Protestant Ethic and The Spirit of Capitalism, published in 1905,
Weber laid out some of the reasons why he believed Protestant Christianity
had been so crucial to capitalism.
In Weber's analysis Catholics have it relatively easy.
They were able to confess their
transgressions at regular intervals
and can be cleansed by priests.
But no such purifications are available to Protestants
who believe that only god is able to forgive anyone
and he won't make his intentions known until the day of judgment.
Until then Weber alleged Protestants are left with
heightened feelings of anxiety
as well as lifelong guilty desires to prove
their virtue to a severe all-seeing but silent god.
In Weber's eyes Protestant feelings of guilt were
diverted into an obsession with hard work.
This was what he called the Protestant
work ethic.
The sins of Adam could only be expunged through constant toil.
Not coincidentally there were far fewer festivals and days of rest in Protestantism.
God didn't like time off.
Catholics had limited their conception
of holy work to the activities of
priests, monks and nuns
but now Protestants declared that work of any kind could be done in the name of God
even jobs like being a baker or an
accountant.
This lent new moral energy and
earnestness to all branches of professional life.
In Catholic countries the family was and
often still is everything.
But Protestants took a less benevolent
view of family.
The family could be a haven for selfish and egoistic motives.
For early Protestants one was meant to direct one's selfless energies to the community as a whole,
the public realm, where everyone deserved fairness and dignity.
Protestantism and eventually scientific capitalism turned its back on miracles.
Weber called this the disenchantment of the world.
So prosperity wasn't to be thought of as
something mysteriously ordained by God,
it could only be the result of thinking
methodically, acting honestly,
and working industriously and sensibly
over many years.
Without a belief in miracles
people turn to science for explanations and changes
which encouraged scientific investigation and discovery
and eventually technological booms.
Taken together these five factors
created, in Weber's eyes,
the crucial catalytic ingredients for
capitalism to take hold.
Marx had argued that religion was the
opium of the masses,
a drug that induced passive acceptance of the horrors of capitalism.
But Weber turned this dictum on its head.
People didn't tolerate capitalism
because of religion.
They only became capitalists as a result
of their religion.
There are about 35 countries where
capitalism is now well developed.
It probably works best in Germany where
Weber first observed it.
But in the remaining 161 nations it arguably isn't working very well at all.
This is a source of much puzzlement and
distress.
Billions of dollars in aid are transferred every year from the rich to the poor parts of the world.
But a Weberian analysis tells us that these materialist interventions will never work
because the problem isn't really a material one to begin with
Instead certain countries for Weber fail to succeed at capitalism because they don't feel anxious and guilty enough.
They trust too much in miracles.
They like to celebrate now rather than
invest in tomorrow
and their members feel it's acceptable to steal from the community
in order to enrich their families favoring the clan over the
nation.
Today, Weber would counsel those who wish to spread capitalism
to concentrate on our equivalent of religion -- culture.
It's a nation's attitudes hopes and a
sense of what life is about
that produces an economy that either
flourishes or flounders.
To reduce poverty, Weber would say one has to start at the level of ideas.
What the World Bank and the IMF should
be giving sub-saharan Africa
is not, in a Weberian analysis, money and technology but a new outlook.
The decisive question for an economy should not be what the rate of inflation is but what's on TV tonight.
Weber was writing in an age of revolution.
He, too, wanted things to change
but he believed that one first had to work out how political power operated.
Weber believed that humanity had gone through three distinct types of power.
The older societies operated according
to what he called traditional authority
where kings relied on folklore and
divinity to justify their power.
Then came the age of charismatic authority
where a heroic individual, most famously Napoleon,
could rise to power with a magnetic personality
and change everything through passion and will.
However, Weber explained that we had now entered a third age of bureaucratic authority.
Bureaucracy achieves its power via knowledge.
Only the bureaucrats know how stuff works
and it will take an outsider years to work it out.
Most of us simply give up, usefully for
the powers that be.
The dominance of bureaucracy has major implications for anyone trying to change a nation.
There is often an understandable but
misguided desire to think that one just has to change the leader.
But in fact removing a leader almost never has the degree of impact that is hoped for.
If we're to get things to go better much
of it will have to come through
outwardly rather undramatic bureaucratic processes.
It will come through the marshalling of statistical evidence, patient briefings to ministers,
testimonies to committee hearings, and a minute study of budgets.
Weber tells us how power works now and reminds us that ideas may be far more important
than tools or money in changing nations.
It's a hugely significant thesis.
With Weber's guidance we learn that so much which we associate with vast, impersonal, external forces
is, in fact, dependent upon something utterly intimate and perhaps more malleable:
the thoughts in our own heads.